the regime was thinking that well these
are kids
they're going to go away and then of
course they're completely
conspiratorial in their thinking
they constantly think that these are all
the
instigations and provocations of foreign
powers these are the great Satan the
United States this is Israel or these
are the it's actually the Supreme data
sets in so many wars
his only response so far that he had in
the first past six weeks with regard to
this demonstrations is that these are
the children of the savac being the
security forces of the shortest time
that's 43 years later
he claims that the children
7 16 17 years 20 years old
kids in the street are the grandchildren
or children of some imaginary
survival of the short security so
there's uh the idea is that these
protests are internal
and external
saboteurs so people trying to sabotage
the government yes and and they are
misled as far as they can go and then
there's the great Satan United States
and other places are uh controlling
sort of uh either controlling the
narrative feeding propaganda or
literally uh sending people
instead they have I don't think even
they have that kind of imagination
precise to see what you have said yeah
that they would say that they're
controlling the narrative they basically
say no these are agents yeah of of the
foreign powers and their families are
all sold out and they are basically lost
their loyalties to the great Islamic
Republic and therefore
they can be treated so brutally they can
be suppressed or brutally which I
haven't actually said what they are
doing because I thought perhaps first we
should talk about who these kids are in
the streets before we move on in about
the response of the government but one
major factor which seems to add to the
anxiety
of well the regime is extremely anxious
now because they are in a position and
it shows that they don't have the lack
of confidence in a sense that they would
see them reacting in a very forceful way
because basically they don't seem to
have that kind of a confidence to allow
this uh this message or the movement to
air to be aired but the one element
which corresponds to that is that there
is a
expatriate population of Iranians
worldwide
they are probably now according to some
estimates close to 4 million even more
Iranians abroad and they're all over the
world from Australia and New Zealand
Japan
Western Europe
uh turkey and United States and Canada
so just to give you one example last
last Saturday
there was a mass demonstrations in
Berlin by the Iranians from Germany and
all over Europe Western Europe
and it was at least I think probably the
conservative estimate was about hundred
thousand
so hundred thousand Iranians showed up
in Berlin demonstrating against the
treatment of the uh women in Iran or the
movement in Iran
the government
thinks obviously this must have been
some
instigation by foreign powers and they
want to destroy the Islamic Republic
and not only that but the propaganda is
kind of ridiculous because I listened
actually to how they portrayed it in the
newspapers I listened to the Iranian
news that is officially controlled
government control news
and and in the paper is the much of the
papers that are in the control of the
government
a one of them or actually the the major
news program portrayed the
demonstrations that 10 000 people
showed up in Berlin and protested
against the rising prices rising rates
for gas and oil in Germany so that's how
they mislead in a very rather just
stupid fashion because
probably 95 percent if not 100 percent
of the Iranians are listening to Passion
speaking media outside Iran so it's a
BBC
person there is Iran International there
are at least five or six of them that's
probably really important to highlight
that
Iran is a very modern and tech savvy
Nation
not just the young people probably more
than more than I feel sometimes when I
compare myself to what they are doing
yeah since 1979 the earlier years for a
decade or two
they tried in a very crude fashion to
restrict and access to Media outside
Iran and because this is all through
dishes okay and satellite dishes are
everywhere you know if you look at the
uh you know
buildings of either a small house small
towns and villages in Iran there's
always a a dish and they watch all kinds
of things through this and particularly
because of what's Happening Now they
listen to all the news
um uh broadcasts from all this media and
they're extremely active they are
um probably some of them even 24 hours
or close very extensive coverage of
every clip that comes through
so what the government is doing now the
Islamic Republic
is that they restrict the entire
internet the shutdown they shot the
internet but they cannot afford shutting
down the internet because much of the
business much of the everyday life much
of the government at first depends on
the internet like everywhere else and
Iran is extremely if
you if I hear from many of the
colleagues and friends you know it's
like in certain respects it's like
Sweden where you go there there's no
more currency and for a very good reason
because there's so much inflation that
that the banknotes are worthless in a
sense so everything is true you know uh
sweeping your card and that's the entire
system is in a standstill because people
cannot buy food they can you you go to
the supermarket that's how you would do
it you you order food to come to your
house which Iranians at least the middle
classes the more prosperously that
Christ is doing all the time so they
deliver everything and because of the
covet it became even more and they have
to pay all through this system
um so what happens is that now they're
estimating that every day 50 million
dollars the Iranian government or the
Iranian economy is losing because of
slowing the internet plus the
frustration is growing of course because
you can't order food
right I mean they are they are in touch
with I mean WhatsApp yeah every Iranian
virtually every Iranian yeah that has
the education and education in the sense
that has gone through
the the high schools and universities
knows how to use the WhatsApp so there's
a big middle class like you said secular
class in Iran and there there's a lot of
at least capacity for if not Revolution
then
um political ideological
uh
turmoil and the huge amount of hatred
so the hatred is grown yes hatred of the
of the policies
of the regime of isolation that's a huge
point that you hear a great deal about
that we don't want to be isolated we
don't want to be humiliated Iran is not
about
this this miserable regime that is
ruling over us
we have a great culture so there's a
sense of a pride
in their own culture some of it's uh you
know Islamic some of it pre-islamic so
they there is a huge um a sense of a
pride in that and they see that they
cannot communicate with the outside
world they they want to travel abroad
which they do I mean for one thing the
Iranian regime never actually
for majority of the population never put
restrictions it's not like Soviet Union
where you have to have a you used to
have a permission to move from one place
to another and then of course the the
Islamic regime since 1979 basically I
chased away or destroyed the old middle
class that's my generation basically my
parents here they say these are the
secular middle class of the palavera in
the hope that they can do this social
engineering and create this Islamic
uh uh Society of Their Own the bad news
for them was that that didn't happen and
that memory
persisted and the middle class that was
created since past 40 years
is much larger in size
than what it was because there was of
course the demographic Revolution that's
the way
there's a very Foundation of it it's the
demographic Revolution
population in Iran I've written an
article about it actually
a population in Iran since uh the turn
of the century last century as 20th
century population of Iran was about 9
million or so
it's now 83 million
and that is since 1979 the population
was 35 million between the past 40 years
it's basically doubled so it's 83
million although
one of the great successes I don't want
to bore you with the details about the
Democracy but it's important
demographics is not important you will
you can see that the best rate was very
high otherwise you wouldn't have doubled
your population in matter of four
decades but Iranians because of the
urban
shift to an urban population because of
the growth of the middle class because
of the education
they basically the pattern of the uh of
growth population growth changed Iran
used to be
2.8 or 3 percent birth rate in around
1980s I would say 1970s 1980s now
it is 1.1
and it's what probably the most
successful country in the Middle East in
terms of the population culture despite
the government
a consistent uh attempt to try to
encourage people to have more kids
middle class refuses to do that and this
is middle class not only anymore in the
capital
but this is very smaller towns and
cities places that used to be villages
now you look at them they have a decent
population 50 000 100
000 and they live in urban life and they
don't want to be
subjected to that old pattern of
agrarian society when you had 10
children or eight children and of course
it's a much more advanced in terms of uh
in terms of health and medicine so you
don't at least lose children as they
used to the antibiotics there's always
of
kids to survive and therefore if you
have 10 kids you're sick with 10 kids
you don't end up with four as it used to
be in the past
six of them would have died in the in
the after the age of five actually but
now because of that you see that this
Urban population in the cities have
completely different demands
and of course the education is important
that's another area of how the social
engineering of the Islamic Republic went
away because they were thinking that you
know the growth of the population the
growth of the educated higher educated
middle classes in their benefit or they
could not even control it in a sense now
Iran in my time uh probably had
in the
1970s probably by the time of the
Revolution about 10 12 universities
now it has 56 universities all across
the country
and there is a something referred to as
the Free University Azad
which has campuses all over the country
it has 324 campuses all around Iran
what does that mean
in many respects this youth
that were brought up in these families
even in a small towns in very
traditional families and families that
belong to that kind of a more religious
loyal to the clergy or to the clerical
classes
their children
can now move on which particularly women
because in in my times it would have
been unheard of that you would have a
young woman of 18 or 17 18 19
from a traditional City such as for
instance Yaz or in in and
statistan Iran
uh to move on elsewhere for Education as
you do in this country okay now it's
completely accepted that a woman
wears their job because he's forced to
wear a job
to go to a university completely on the
other side of the country
and this movement of the population
not only because of the universities but
in general
if you now visit Iran
you hear accents local accents
provincial accents all over the country
that is a azerbaijani Turkish accent
from the north
west of the country you can hear it in
the forest province in the South and
vice versa
so
and Kurdish for instance or even more
marginal regions such as system province
in the southeast of Iran which has been
the subject of this recent Massacre when
they actually attacked the population
when demonstrating and killed a fair
number at least 60 people
so this movement of the population
this creation of a larger middle class
the better educated middle class much
better educated Iran has 86 percent uh
uh literacy
which I think probably I haven't checked
that but probably is better than turkey
even is probably better than anywhere
else in the Middle East and it sounds
like there's a that's quickly increasing
so because because of the movement
because of the growth that the education
system that's precisely Iran has one
million School teachers
which may not seem as much if you are in
the United States but it's a fairly big
number